anyway Bloomingdale's pulled a shirt off
a mannequin bearing the words fake news
after a triggered reporter tweeted a
photo saying the shirt D legitimizes
hard-working journalists I'm not sure
how I shirt on a dummy does that I wear
a lot of shirts with slogans and this
dummy has no impact on anyone I actually
own an anarchy in the UK shirt and I've
yet to topple a government yet but this
isn't really about shirts it's about the
modern spineless corporation cowed by a
tweet reacted like dandelions in a
strong wind a spokesperson said quote we
apologise to anyone who found this
t-shirt distressing as if distressed
shirts are the problem but as you know
once you apologize you just egg on those
who are bored another member of the
press safety patrol tweeted at
Bloomingdales
that it's apology wasn't sincere please
try again the tweet dripped as if a
thousand apologies could ever satisfy
those who sniff fear so good job
Bloomingdale's today one dummy in a
storefront window is cold and topless
while another dummy scores the scalpels
I can hardly wait to see where this is
headed I saw a mannequin in Soho wearing
fishnet stockings fishnets there used to
trap fish what kind of message does that
send our youth mmm strong finish there
all right one I'm gonna do your job for
you today thank you alright be wrong but
Greg but Greg last night a reporter was
shoved at a trump rally by a surly drunk
who was shouting fake news could this
shirt have contributed to that to which
I say no one they never saw this shirt
and if you notice it's a trump supporter
holding back that drunk sure so now you
can move on to another guest yes yes I
wanted I wanted to undercut your points
well I think it's real I just I hope you
understand that people can be offended
like for example this business that's
going on right now with is it Katy Perry
shoes yeah it look like blackface right
and then people say hey that's offensive
and so then they pull it I mean there's
certain things that you don't want
it's a weird-looking shoe but one you're
not offended by a fake news t-shirt are
you I don't like it if that's what
you're not
okay I wouldn't buy that's exact but I
think but I think that when you're
talking about the kind of suggestion by
the way this came from a local New York
City TV reporter and given another
reporter and everybody else what people
what people are reacting to is the enemy
the press thing right what you know what
the thing is Kennedy you were an
operator of sarcasm you could be wearing
the fake news shirt ironically yeah you
could actually be wearing a news
broadcast out of news yes kind of it's a
symbol against Trump I'm wearing fake
news because I think it's a joke it's
one of those phrases that has been
inserted into our modern lexicon and
that's okay and it's funny to poke fun
of things like that and that's exactly
what they're doing it's not a trump 2020
campaign not it's not a Bloomingdale's
definitely no it's all it's doing is
showing sarcastically that this phrase
is ubiquitous and it's making fun of
that I don't have a problem that I do
have a problem with the outrage and the
apology like I'm so offended that you're
taking aim at a hard-working journalist
that's not the intent and that's not
good yeah and if fashion does startle
people if it does jar you a little bit
good for them that's what it's supposed
to do
fashion is supposed to be unapologetic
like dolce gabbana dolce gabbana make
fun of everyone they make fun of
everyone and they don't care if you're
Selena Gomez or ariana grande they will
make fun of you which is great there's
not enough of that in the world there's
not enough pointing out absurdity
there's too much apologizing and too
much easy offense and I'm done with it
all right Kennedy Morgan it's true
though it's like you look at this it's
it's not a Trump t-shirt and still the
reporters like offended yeah I think
that the untold success story and all of
this is for Bloomingdale's actually they
responded to the treat right away and I
love Bloomingdale's I think they have
excellent customer service I treated
this is my shoes this is terrible no I
think it's good they respond to their
cuz that's idiotic they should not be on
Twitter because they got bad [ __ ] right
how about this new shoes with social
change
put the shell into the shoe on the other
foot let's say you say something on the
five right and that because that one
person out there in outer space is
offended by and they can and they cut
and they they contact Fox and Fox goes
we are so sorry that Morgan Ortega
wouldn't you be pissed off if they'd if
they didn't support you isn't that
called media that's my point is what is
companies are no longer standing by
anything I think blue Marino's was
awesome and they have good customer
service you are this is so selfish of
you you oh gosh that's so Greg you know
what it is I was gonna get this shirt
but I don't look good in yellow so I'm
quiet but this is about there will be
your intent this is the breadth of the
reporters who can dish it out but they
can't take it think about all the
industries that reporters have attacked
the NRA the military the police
department the NFL Fox News talk radio
all this stuff the minute you say
anything about their industry they lock
it down you can't criticize right how do
they have to maintain their status and
if their status is threatened they run a
mob at you yeah all right